大家好,
我是Jim,
這裡是AI Notebook,
這一集看OpenAI放上網路的700多篇AI數學論文,
只問兩個問題,
他們解決了什麼,
又驗證到哪裡,
臺灣時間10月7日清晨,
OpenAI在Github上開了一個資料夾,
名字就叫Math,
你點進去,
目錄一直往下捲,
捲了很久還沒到底,
裡面有圓周率,
有黎曼猜想,
還有一道千禧年難題,
每一篇的作者欄都只寫著OpenAI,
我們分三段走,
先花一點時間看OpenAI為什麼要做這件事,
再看他說自己解決了什麼,
最後看,
這些說法驗證了什麼,
先從為什麼開始
為什麼要做這件事
答案在資料夾裡的
一份說明文件裡面
有一句話是整件事的起點
他說
模型
在現有的數學評估上
已經飽和了
評估英文叫Evaluation
就是AI公司
拿來考自己模型的考卷
飽和
就是題目他幾乎都會了
分數已經頂到天花板
再考也看不出他有沒有變強
這就像一個學生
把書店裡所有的
數學練習簿都寫完了
每一本都拿滿分
再買一本也沒用
因為答案都在書後面
要知道他還有沒有進步
只能拿一道書
後面沒有答案的題目給他
這種題目
數學界叫開放問題
題目大家都知道
可是還沒有人解決
為什麼挑數學
因為數學的對錯
可以一步一步檢查
這一點後面會用到
OpenAI的模型
之前在國際數學奧林匹亞
拿過金牌水準
那還是有標準答案的題目
這一次
他把考卷換成了
沒有人寫過答案的題目
新考卷怎麼考
說明文件寫得很具體
大部分的結果
用的是同一套固定流程
做題的是一個
還沒公開的內部模型
他們總共丟了
想三個小時
做完以後
不夠重要的被塞掉
最後留到三百多組
結果寫成七百多篇論文
這裡要小心
七百多篇
不是七百多個難題
很多篇是同一組結果
一篇主要的證明
加上從他推出來的其他定理
那剩下的題目呢
四千題裡
留下來的只是一小部分
OpenAI
沒有主題說明
其他是做不出來
還是被塞掉
從這個流程看得出
他要的不是一個
很會考試的模型
而是一個能做研究的模型
差別很簡單
考試有人先知道答案
研究沒有
OpenAI也說
它會繼續拿數學和其他科學來評估模型
數學只是第一個考場
考場之外
OpenAI還有一個更難的問題
就是怎麼把結果交給數學界
讓人願意相信
這件事跟標題後半句的驗證到哪裡直接相關
9月初
OpenAI宣佈模型解決了一道跟水流有關的千禧年難題
9月下旬
它有說解決了100多個老問題
可是一篇證明都還沒有公開
看不到證明
數學家就沒辦法驗證
那時候數學圈已經在流傳一封公開信
標題叫AI在數學上的嚴重錯位
連署的人理陶哲軒也在裡面
陶哲軒是加州大學洛杉磯分校的教授
拿過費爾茲獎
也就是數學界最高的榮譽之一
常被稱為當代最頂尖的數學家之一
後面還會再聽到他
心裡擔心的是
解答只是過程中的一個里程碑
真正的目的是理解
題目被AI一題一題收走
卻沒有人理解
這個領域反而會變得貧瘠
OpenAI的回應
是請數學家成立一個顧問團
設在普林斯頓的高等研究院
成員有九位數學家
不拿OpenAI的錢
也不能替他做決定
9月底顧問團公開了一份建議
要AI公司交代清楚三件事
模擬名稱提示詞和花費
另外也要盡量讓電腦檢查證明
這一次OpenAI做到了一部分
他附上很多讓電腦檢查的證明
還有十份推理摘要
可是模型的名字沒有公開
論文也還放在OpenAI自己的Github上
放上Github
是OpenAI在信任問題上走的第一步
背景大概就是這樣
OpenAI做這件事
是想解決他自己的兩個問題
一個是考試的問題
練習不寫完了
他需要沒有答案的題目
證明模型能做研究
另一個是信任的問題
結果交出去要怎麼讓人相信
顧問團和電腦檢查是他的答案
但還不是完整的答案
現在回到標題的前半句
模型真正去碰的題目到底解決了什麼
他碰的題目先從整張地圖看
OpenAI附了一份總覽
把300多組結果
分成17個領域
你可以把它想成一張程式地圖
17個區每一區是數學的一個方向
結果最多的一區是理論電腦科學
研究電腦能多快多省力的算出答案
接下來是組合數學代數集合和數論
最大的那一區裡
有一題
跟每個人都有關
它叫矩陣乘法
是電腦做大量計算時最常用的一種運算
AI本身也靠它運作
我朋友說
他找到了更快的做法
比數學家幾十年來一點一點往前推的紀錄
快了一大截
還有一件事
大部分的結果是證明某個說法成立
可是大約每六七組
就有一組剛好相反
是證明大家相信的某個說法其實不成立
這叫推翻
不過要記得
整張地圖上的每一面棋子
都還是OpenAI自己插的
還沒經過別人驗證
每一面棋子
都代表OpenAI說
它解決了一個問題
可是解決到底是什麼意思
我要先講兩個名詞
猜想和證明
猜想是很多數學家都相信
卻還沒有人能證明的說法
證明是從大家公認的事實出發
一步一步推到這個說法
我們用法庭來想
猜想
像是大家都覺得
某個人就是兇手
可是還沒定罪
證明是一條完整的證據鏈
每一環都要扣上
少一環就不能定罪
剛剛說的推翻
就是找到一個反例
證明那個人其實不是兇手
所以OpenAI說
它解決了一個猜想
意思是它交出了一條完整的鏈
不管是定罪還是犯案
這一集從地圖上挑四題來看
前兩題
一句話就問得完
後兩題
有名到數學系以外的人
也可能聽過
這四題的順序還有一個意思
就是電腦檢查做到哪裡
越前面的
檢查做得越完整
越後面的
越只能先聽OpenAI
先聽最好懂的一題
圓周率π
π是一個無理數
它沒辦法寫成
兩個整數相除的分數
它的小數一直寫下去
不會停也不會循環
可是分數可以靠近它
7分之22
小數點後兩位就跟π一樣
113分之355
小數點後六位都一樣
我們用買東西來想
分數底下那個數叫分母
分母越大
就像你付的錢越多
付越多錢
買到的準度越高
這很正常
數學家想知道的是
π有沒有特價品
也就是
有沒有一些分數
分母不大
確準的不正常
衡量這件事的量尺
叫無理數值數
它量的就是付出去的錢
跟買到的準度
是什麼比例
絕大多數的數都沒有特價品
付多少錢就買到多少準度
大家一直猜π是這樣
可是幾十年來
數學家只能證明它的特價不會太誇張
卻證明不了它一點特價都沒有
OpenAI說
它的模型證明了π沒有特價品
這一題附了另的電腦檢查
主要的定理有被檢查到
換回正式的說法
圓周率沒辦法被分數逼得特別近
它跟絕大多數的數一樣普通
普通的數一個一個看
沒什麼特別
排成一串就可能藏著規律
這一題的主角叫等差數列
等差數列
就是間隔一樣的一串數
像1 4 7 10
每次都加3
我們用一條街來想
在街邊的一些空地上種樹
等差數列
就是一排間隔一樣的樹
提出這一題的人叫Erdos
一位很愛出題
還常自己出錢懸賞的數學家
他問
如果你種的樹夠多
那不管你要多長的
一排等距離的樹
是不是都找得到
夠多有個精確的標準
這裡先不細講
直覺上樹種的共鳴
就藏得住規律
可是要證明
非常難
支數就是一個例子
只在支數的位置種樹
數量剛好符合ERDOS的標準
光是證明支數里找得到任意場的等差數列
就要等到2004年
由陶哲軒和另一位數學家完成
OpenAI說
它的模型證明了整個猜想
不只支數
只要數字夠多
就找得到任意場的等差數列
這一題也附了電腦檢查
可是範圍要講清楚
電腦檢查的是這一句結論
論文裡另一個更細的數量估計
沒有被檢查
在這一題裡
支數只是配角
下一題
支數變成主角
它是數學裡最有名的問題之一
黎曼猜想
前兩題一句話就問得完
這一題難得多
我們慢慢來
要講這一題
得先認識Zeta數
Zeta是一個希臘字母
Zeta數是一個公式
跟指數怎麼分佈緊緊
綁在一起
你可以把它想成一張
指數的地圖
讀懂它就知道
指數大概會出現在哪裡
地圖上有一些特別的點
叫零點
也就是Zeta數
剛好等於零的位置
你可以把零點
想成地圖上的燈
燈的位置
決定了指數有多少規矩
這些燈
全部落在地圖上的
一條河道里
左岸叫0右岸叫1
黎曼猜想說
所有的燈都排在河道正中間
也就是一半的那條線上
如果這是真的
植樹的規律會非常整齊
可是到今天還沒有人證明
人類真正確定的
只有右岸上沒有燈
靠近右岸也有一小塊地方沒有燈
麻煩的是
往上游走得越遠
這塊地方就越窄
窄到幾乎貼著右岸
所以沒有人能在河道里
蓋得到筆直的圍籬
說圍籬右邊一盞燈都沒有
能蓋出這道圍籬
就叫準離漫猜想
OpenAI說
它的模型把違離蓋在八分之七的位置
換回正式的說法
在八分之七的右邊
Zeta數沒有零點
這裡離漫猜想還很遠
正中間在一半
違離在八分之七
中間還隔著將近四成的寬度
可是違離沒往中間推一步
我們預測之數就準一截
如果它是對的
這是第一次有人蓋出這樣一道違離
這一題負了令的電腦檢查
不過OpenAI也註明
這一題的做法
跟其他題目的固定流程不一樣
不照固定流程做的
還有最後這一題
而且他連電腦檢查都還沒有
它是最難用白話講的一題
Hodge猜想
也是七道遷徙的難題之一
這段我第一次讀
也讀得很吃力
所以我們只抓一個畫面
數學家研究一些
很高維度的形狀
我們看不見
只能用方程式寫下來
在這些形狀上
有一種痕跡
叫Hodge類
我們用影子來想
Hodge類
就像牆上的影子
看起來很像是某個東西
投出來的
Hodge猜想問的是
每一個這樣的影子
背後是不是真的
真的都有一個實體
而且這個實體能用方程式寫出來
OpenAI
這次沒有說它解決了整個Hodge猜想
整個猜想像一棟大樓
OpenAI說它蓋好的
只是其中一層
那一層是一類特別對稱的形狀
名字很長
比較有複數稱法的阿貝爾處
不用記
你只要知道它很對稱
所以手上能用的工具比較多
OpenAI說
在這類形狀上
影子背後都有實體
換回正式的說法
Hodge猜想在這類形狀上成立
可是這一題要注意兩件事
它沒有附令的電腦檢查
而且跟黎曼那一題一樣
它不是照固定流程做出來的
是體力
它最有名
也是檢查做的最少的一體
實體看完
所以解決了什麼
照OpenAI的說法
有四件事
圓周率
沒辦法被分數逼得特別近
數字夠多
就找得到任一長的等差數列
Zeta數在7%的右邊沒有零點
Hodge
猜想在一類特別對稱的形狀上成立
可是每一句前面
都要加上OpenAI
說因為他們被檢查的程度不一樣
圓周率那一句
主要的定理有電腦檢查
等差數列那一句
結論有電腦檢查
更細的估計沒有
黎曼那一句
有電腦檢查
可是做法不在固定流程裡
Hodge那一句
沒有電腦檢查
也不在固定流程裡
這裡有一件有點尷尬的事
越有名的題目
越要等數學家自己去讀
那要等多久
威斯康星大學的數學家
Jordan Allenberg
也寫過暢銷的數學科普書
他的回答很樂觀
他說結果真的很多
但時間會過去
數學家會慢慢研究
看能拿它們做什麼
他希望答案是很多
而且不用急
可是在大家慢慢研究之前
得先知道這些說法
站不站得住
也就是標題的後半句
驗證到哪裡
你要知道驗證到哪裡
先看數學界
平常怎麼確認一個證明是對的
傳統的方法叫同差審查
英文是peer review
我們用蓋房子來想
一篇論文
就像一棟剛蓋好的房子
同差審查
就是請集會同行的老師傅
一間一間走進去
敲敲牆壁
看看管線
找漏水和裂縫
這是很慢
短了幾個月
長了好幾年
漫有他的道理
當年數學家懷爾斯宣佈
證明了費馬最後定理
一道放了幾百年的難題
審查的人卻發現
證明裡有一個漏洞
他又花了一年多才把漏洞補起來
連最頂尖的數學家
蓋出來的房子也會漏水
現在換成OpenAI這次的規模
700多棟房子一次蓋好
每一棟都在很偏僻的地方動
那一區的老師傅可能就那麼幾個人
照傳統的速度
光是看完
可能就要好幾年
所以OpenAI想先用另一種方法擋一層
就是讓電腦檢查證明
讓電腦檢查證明的工具叫LIN
它是一種專門用來檢查證明的程式語言
LIN會把證明的每一步
都寫成電腦看得懂的樣子
再讓電腦一步一步確認
只要有一步是跳過的
或是說不清楚的
它就不給過
把證明翻譯成LIN
這個動作叫隱私化
英文是formalization
我們用倉庫收穫來想
LIN
就像一臺很嚴格的收穫機器
一個證明就是一個箱子
箱子外面貼著一張標籤
寫這裡面裝的是哪一個定理
機器保證的是
就是箱子裡的東西
跟標籤寫的一模一樣
一顆螺絲都沒少
可是標籤本身有沒有寫對
機器不管
標籤寫的是不是你真正想問的題目
要人自己讀
OpenAI就是這樣安排的
每一題都附一張很短的標籤
只有幾行字
像黎曼那一題
標籤寫的就是在7%的右邊
Zeta數不等於0
證明本身非常龐大
但人只要讀懂這幾行
另外還有一個工具
確認證明只用了三條公認的基本公理
就是大家都同意
不用再證明的出發點
這批論文放上網路不到一天
就有人自己把黎曼那一帖的
Lin證明編譯了一次
全部通過
不過他也說得很清楚
他檢查的是Lin證明
不是那篇論文
而且只在一臺電腦上做了一次
那論文本身呢
有一位數學家認為
應該以Lin為準
他是Kevin Buzzard
倫敦帝國學院的教授
正在帶頭用Lin把廢碼
最後定理整個檢查一遍
就在這批論文
放上網路的五天前
他公開呼籲OpenAI
把手上的定理全部放出來
讓大家看清楚
他到底宣稱做了什麼
在他看來
令的程式碼才是最可靠的依據
論文寫得亂
之後可以再整理
如果要以令為準
那這次到底有多少題有令
照OpenAI的目錄
300多組結果裡
大約6成多負了令
如果一篇一篇算
大約是一半
這已經很多了
可是讀這個數字
要像讀健康檢查報告
報告上檢查過的項目寫得正常
沒檢查的項目是空白
空白不代表沒病
只代表沒檢查
這次的報告
有三件事要看
首先
很多令只檢查主要定理的一部分
雲州綠內體的推論
等差數列內體的估計
都還是空白
再來
OpenAI自己的清單上
人工審查那一欄寫的是
還沒有檢查
清單也寫著
隱私化是AI agent做的
Agent
就是能自己一步一步執行任務的AI程式
換句話說
電腦拿來比對的那幾行定理陳述
是AI寫的
還沒有人一條一條讀過
最後剩下的部分根本沒有另
Arch內體就在裡面
對 這部分OpenAI在說明文件裡寫得很坦白
還沒隱私化的結果
可能有問題會盡快修正
他也說以後的修正都會留下記錄
舊版本不會刪掉
報告上這些空白
電腦補不了
只能靠人
就看數學家怎麼讀
先講清楚
這批結果放上網絡還不到一天
所有的反應都還很早
科學人雜誌當天訪問了兩位數學家
看法剛好相反
比較謹慎的
是Andrew Sutherland
麻省理工學院的數學家
研究數論
也很常用電腦做計算
他說在模型公開
別人能做出同樣的結果之前
這些說法都該當時還沒確認
他的原話是
我們應該要看收據
比較樂觀的
是Daniel Leet
多倫多大學的數學家
常在網路上談AI做數學
他說
如果想知道這些問題的答案
沒有理由要公司
把答案藏起來
這對數學是好事
可是就算答案都放出來了
誰來讀
這正是陶哲軒擔心的事
他在OpenAI
公告前幾個小時
剛好發了一串文章
要說清楚
他談的不是這批結果
對不對
而是整個趨勢
他說
以前一個重大的證明出來
大家會聽演講
開研討會
一起合作
證明會被慢慢消化
最後寫進教科書
可是現在
難題被大量收割
卻沒有人消化
而且一道題被宣佈解決就回不去了
顧問團當天的聲明也是同一個意思
他們說
公開只是人類理解這些結果的開始
不是完成他們當顧問
也不代表替這些結果背書
到我們做這集為止
還沒有人公開指出哪一篇是錯的
但也才過了一天
才過了一天
能說的就是這些
所以驗證到哪裡
可以分成三層
第一層有令
而且層數又短又清楚
像圓周率那一題
電腦確認的證明一步不漏
那幾行陳述人也讀得懂
很可能是真的解決了
再來有Ling
但只檢查了一部分的
像等差數列那題的估計
還有空白要補
最後沒有Ling的
像Hodge那一題
現在只能說是OpenAI的說法
最有名的幾題
剛好落在檢查最少的那一邊
而且就算全部都對
還有一個新問題才剛出現
這些證明有了
卻還沒有人真正讀懂
陶澤軒擔心的就是這個
題目解決了
跟數學家理解了
是兩件事
前者
後者電腦可以幫忙檢查
後者只能靠人慢慢讀
再慢慢講給下一個人聽
這需要時間
時間會給出更完整的答案
現在先回到標題的兩個問題
解決了什麼
OpenAI說
它的模型碰了圓周率等差數列
黎曼猜想Hodge猜想這些放了幾十年
甚至上百年的題目
交出300多組結果
驗證到哪裡
大約六成多負了令的電腦檢查
但檢查的範圍還沒有人一條一條核對
剩下的包括最有名的Hodge
還要等數學家一篇一篇讀
最後問一個問題
如果一道難題是AI證明的
電腦也檢查過了
可是還沒有人真正看懂
你覺得它算是被解決了嗎?
留言告訴我
喜歡的話訂閱AI Notebook
開啟通知
我們下次見